this is a CBS News special report I'm
Anthony Mason in New York the Labor
Department's April unemployment report
has just come out confirming historic
levels of job losses last month it shows
just how devastating the coronavirus has
been to the economy CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger joins us Jill
as the news as bad as we expected right
on target a catastrophic number 20 point
five million Americans unemployed in the
month of April the unemployment rate is
at fourteen point seven percent the
previous month where we thought we had
700,000 that was revised even lower down
beyond 800,000 these numbers are
staggering they're devastating when you
think about it this is 25 times worse
than any single month that we saw in the
Great Recession 10 times worse than the
worst month on record which is right
after World War two so Anthony I don't
even know if I can put this in
historical context because it is just so
unbelievable to see a 20 million print
yeah Jill we've been following the
weekly numbers for the last number of
weeks or six or seven weeks and over
seven weeks there were we have 33
million unemployed claims so how does
this factor into that well you know
these are two different surveys the the
unemployment benefits that people claim
on a weekly basis you do that through
your state and it tends to be a leading
indicator these monthly month numbers
don't forget they're captured as of the
the week in which the 12th day of the
month Falls so we know there's far more
people in the second half of April who
were unemployed probably many more
millions that will come on to these
numbers when we see revisions and also
when we see the May report I think these
April main numbers are just going to be
really awful whether these folks come
back sooner rather than later that would
be the key to helping so many of the
families that are impacted by this
catastrophe Jewellery seeing any
evidence of a cascading in effect
meaning that when you
people who were laid off and out of work
obviously they're not going to spend
money that leads businesses to having
losses and having to lay off more people
do we see that happening here well we
have the emerging evidence that it could
happen and we really want to be careful
because these are early days still but
for example yesterday the Federal
Reserve came out with a report about
consumer borrowing in March that number
went negative for the first time since
2011 when people borrow less - they tend
to spend less and if people are going to
spend less in this economy this could be
a deeper and longer lasting recession
than the much hoped for V that we were
talking about just a month ago yeah all
right Jill Schlessinger thanks so much
our coverage will continue on our
24-hour streaming network cbsn you can
watch it at CBS news.com or on our CBS
news app